democrats have been in charge of the
white house the senate the house of
representatives now for over a month
and it has been well pretty much an
unmitigated disaster
setting back the country in numerous
ways to say the least
their first order of business was a
weeks-long all-consuming
political stunt the impeachment charade
with a
predetermined outcome and nothing at all
accomplished
ending with an acquittal their second
order of business was
legislation that if passed would ban
president trump from the capitol grounds
forever
and even arlington national cemetery
after he dies
in the middle of a pandemic where over a
hundred thousand
americans died during joe biden's time
in the white house
raging against president trump was still
the democratic party and the media mob's
top priority
they also just introduced legislation
that would further
undermine election integrity and also
provide congressional voting rights to
washington d.c
clearly while the same democrats have
been in no particular rush to pass a
covet relief package
and get money into the hands of
americans who actually need it now
they're finally getting around to that
with a massive
1.9 not million not
billion trillion dollar spending bill
and
unfortunately it's a little more than a
wish list for the radical left
masquerading as a covert relief package
wall street journal rightly calling it
the non-covet spending blowout
aside from direct 1400 dollar payments
to americans many of whom need it
the bulk of spending is unrelated to
getting
immediate assistance to our fellow
americans
in need through no fault of their own in
fact nearly 700 billion dollars won't
even be
spent until after 2022
including billions that won't be spent
until after
2024. so we must ask ourselves tonight
how is that covet relief a whopping 350
billion is earmarked
as a bailout for state and local
governments
which to translate for you means that
red states that elect fiscally
responsible governors and legislatures
that balance their budgets fund their
pensions that have low
taxes well their hard-earned tax dollars
from people in their states
will be then transferred to big blue
states
that have only mismanaged their budgets
never balance their budgets tax their
residents into oblivion
and never fund their pensions in other
words put it nicely welcome to the
biden united socialist utopia of america
in other words money from fiscally
responsible states
you vote for politicians that are
fiscally responsible
well that money will likely be going to
places like new york and california
which are grossly mismanaged wrought
with political corruption
and the spending package also sets aside
50 million dollars for
environmental justice grants 112 million
for a
transit project in california you know
where nancy pelosi lives
1.5 billion dollars for the seaway
international bridge which connects
canada to new york
oh chuck schumer's home state 10 million
dollars for
a native american language preservation
program
500 million for museums and libraries
up and here we go again the arts and
humanities
they will get a ton more money 40
billion for colleges universities
which have been collecting tuition the
entire time
750 million for quote global health
global health in other words health care
for people
in other countries that's america last
again
and last but not least a billion dollars
for quote
socially disadvantaged farmers
and according to a fox news report that
would include
an equity commission and other
assistance to advance
racial justice in farming and get this
according to the chairwoman of the
progressive caucus
the bill will include a 15 federal
minimum wage mandate
the cbo is reporting that this would
result in the elimination
of 1.4 million jobs at a time
when millions of americans are out of
work and more every day as
joe biden with a stroke of a pen is
literally
eliminating high-paying career jobs in
the energy sector
of course no democrat spending bill is
complete without subsidies for illegal
immigrants
federal money for abortions if passed
don't worry planned parenthood they will
now qualify
for ppp small business loans which then
become grants
and bridges to canada environmental
justice equity commissions
for farmers health care and other
countries now
also a budget bailout really for new
york
for andrew cuomo for gavin newsom in
california
this is not a serious thoughtful covert
relief package
what this really is is a massive federal
payout
to everyone and every state that donated
to
and supported democratic candidates in
2020.
even during a global crisis the left is
constantly playing political games